alhamdulillah I'm a Muslim now and my
journey into Islam started in 2010
Ramadan I honestly as I was growing I
never liked Muslims I was I I grew up
from a community where the head Islam so
much and from a family where Islam is
never tolerated in such surrounding it
was really I mean dream for you to even
think of becoming a Muslim in such a in
such a family so I never liked Muslims
and I never even wish to talk to any
Muslim at all in my entire life but even
though aside the hatred I had for Islam
I always felt something deep down in in
me that I just like the dressing of the
Muslim women
I like the hijab and other stuff stuff
is done by the Muslim women I just
didn't like the religion per se by just
the dress no because
women and being a Christian for some
time I had my own doubts about
Christianity even though it wasn't
really a lot for me to ask about those
problems I didn't really like about
Christianity but did die within me I
felt it wasn't right for us to do that
but that was the religion I grew up from
and it was hard you know comments
negatively about those practices I just
I just needed more I wanted more in
terms of salvation and alhamdulillah
Allah got me here now